hello youtube just Louis and my fence
this is grunge in here welcome to the
14th episode of dirty chest tricks after
the water
efore Aoife and Bishop to c4 in my
earlier dirty trick video I have covered
the Moon Knight to c6 d6 and the move
Bishop to c5 in this episode I'm going
to concentrate blacks one of the main
reply that is Knight to f6 by the way I
have changed the interface so you can
see the board over here you can see me
commentating over here there's a
notations over here and finally the most
important part is you can see the engine
analysis over here that means you can
evaluate the position exactly now as
usual in my recruiter I'm going to
suggest a very aggressive line and Here
I am going to recommend the move d4 and
the funny thing is not many black
players are feeling comfortable about it
for example the main move over here is e
caps is d4 but we should see what will
happen if black plays other moves
so the first more I want to consider is
Knight captures efore after this move
the simplest replies you capture this
pawn and now not only that Knight is
misplaced but there's a nasty trick in
the air looming so in one quick game my
opponent routinely turn out is move that
is Knight to c6 but this leads to the
instant disaster did you spot it yup
is Bishop captures f7 BAM after King
takes and Queen check not only where he
will regain his piece but black king is
clearly misplaced and on top of
everything
what has an extra pawn so that cannot be
recommended for the black the same can
be said if you oppor in play is the move
such as d6 because the very paths you
move and you can immediately exploit
this with the move D captures e-file D
captures e-file and Bishop captures f7
well it's not that you're gaining black
Queen because after Queen captures Queen
Black has this track that is Bishop to
b4 miss cover attacked the Queen so
white has to drop his queen back to the
d2 but after Bishop captures Knight
captures after the whole transaction
like emerge with a clear upon advantage
and a better position
so with this analysis we can easily
conclude that the best move here is e
captures d4 and after this I'm going to
recommend a very Agora C or also gambit
starting with the move Knight to f3 well
with this move wide offer the e4 pawn
and believe it or not but the best move
over here for the black is to capturing
this form but with my own experience
what I found out is especially below mm
many players get afraid of capturing the
second pot they feel that that way their
development will be very bad and there
is some nice trick so they try to get a
word of it so what I have done is in
this lecture I am going to concentrate
on the line where black decline this
gambit and in my next lecture I am going
to concentrate where black is going to
accept that
efore pawn so what are the ways black
and decline this gambit well as I
highlighted over here black has a quite
different choices and we are going to
see some nasty tricks in all of them so
the first move I want to consider is
Knight to c6 well against this the
simplest reply is you do a castle on the
Kings side and once again if you open
plays the move Bishop to c5 or Knight
catches e4 then we enter into the max
length and the Mafia tech territory
which I have covered in detail dirty
justic sixth and the seventh episode so
the only independent move over here is
defy well against this I am recommending
that you capture this fall and now if
you open plays the Moon Knight to be
four then the Bishop to g4 is a very
strong move so the only good reply over
here is to recapturing this pawn with
the night but after this I have
specially cooked a nice move which will
give you great victory in opening and
that mu is Knight to g5 well what's the
idea that is very simple you are going
to sacrifice your
on App seven no matter what black will
do let's see some examples if black
lives at six well you sacrifice your
night and after King takes and Queen
check if black wants to hold on to his
peas then he has to come forward but
then we can play the move rook to even
check and now the only good way to
defend this is to place the knight on e5
afterwards White has this little move
that is Bishop to f4 and not only White
will regain his piece but plaquing will
hardly survive in this open position
here my opinion played the move Bishop
to d6 but then after Queen to defy it is
a last long okay let's see what happens
if other moves for example instead of at
six if you open and plays the move
Bishop to e6
well pitted with same story here first
you are going to play the moon rook to
e1 and when the black defend the bishop
with the move Queen to d7 and now you
are going to sacrifice with Knight xf7
if Queen takes then defy Knight will
drop so the obvious move is Qian
captures but afterwards we can do the
pretty much same story so right we
replay the move Queen to f3 check if
King goes to the e-file then the defy
Knight will drop so in this game my
opponent played the MU King to g8 but he
completely missed my next move
that is yup rook captures a six bear so
the Queen cannot take the route because
after Bishop captures defy black will
lose the Queen so those are some of the
wonderful tricks if you're operating
plays the move knight c6 and the move
defy okay now the second do I want to
consider where here is the immediate D
file now what we should do against this
well pretty much same setup what I'm
recommending over here is you capture
this pawn and there are two ways Black
has tried in this position so the first
is recapturing this pawn and the second
is Bishop to b4 check now Bishop to b4
check the lines will be transposition
which I am going to cover at the end of
this video so let's check out what will
happen after Knight captures d5 well
again
this I'm recommending a very simple move
that is castle on the Kings side and now
if black doesn't hang on to his phone
then white has a very good leading
development and white can gain his
material back
so in other words black has to hang on
to his pawns there are two ways he can
do it the number one is to play the move
C fight immediately but this is a
blunder move and the easiest way to
exploit this is how the same old trick
you play the move Knight to g5 and no
matter what black will do you sacrifice
your 19 f7 so that means the good move
is night to b6 attacking the bishop well
no matter
a bishop will drop back and now only
good way to hang on to this one is to
play the Moosey fire at this point well
that's a good side for the black but the
downside is White has a very aggressive
move that is Knight to e5 and it's a
kind of very hard to defend on f7 so for
example if Bishop to e6 then you capture
this bishop you give this check please
note if g6 then Knight captures g6 and
if black foolishly played the move King
to e7 yeah Bishop to g5 and that Queen
is a goner so that means if black wants
to save the f7 then he has to play the
move c4 at this point well if this is
the base black and have it then I have a
doubt that black and survive in this
position because the simplest repetition
is you capture this pawn and after
Knight captures and Bishop captures not
only White has a leading development but
black has an isolated pawn which can be
ready-made target for the rest of the
game the third move black and try over
here is Bishop to c5 which is
recommended by GM GM goof assassin from
the Germany and it's a very tricky move
I found an advantageous line for the
white in some depth analysis so I just
like to show you that analysis here I'm
recommending that white should continue
with the movie 5 and after as analysis
continues that is d4
i ECAP choose and D captures white give
this check and after Bishop to e6 we
should capture the spawn and after rook
to g8 we played the move Bishop to g5 so
the whole idea is after Queen to d7
white plays the move Knight to d2
regaining his pawn pack now as I
suggested the best move over here is d3
and after this move certain Levi should
capture this pawn and the best reply
over here is Queen captures because if C
captures then Queen to e5 is a very good
reply so the Queen captures d3 is forced
and now I'm recommending that you should
just exchange this Queen and then castle
on the Kings side now GM has stopped his
analysis over here and saying that this
position is quite good for black but I
think we missed somewhere down the line
White has an advantage so let me show
you how white can obtain an advantage
obvious response over here is route
captures g7 now white will continue with
the move Knight to e4 hitting the bishop
also there is a threat of Knight to f6
so the nation replies Bishop to e7 here
why should capture this bishop and after
King takes now we get our pawn back with
an interest that is rook to d1 and
kindly note a Bishop to c4 the Knight to
e5 a very strong move so accordingly the
best move suggested by the engine that
is bishop to defy but again this doesn't
stop us to getting of a pawn back with a
very good position I reach this position
in one of my game where I continue with
the move Knight to g5 and he responded
with the move at six but it doesn't stop
it I capture this pawn hitting his
bishop and after the move c6 I simply
drop my knight back to the h3 and if you
compare this position fight clearly has
a slight advantage the simple reason is
what has this compact pawn structure on
the Kings side where black has a
shattered pawns on the King side which
can be the great asset at the endgame
and not to mention black is behind in
development so all I know this is a
wonderful position for white the fourth
and somewhat most critical noise
to be four check now against this I'm
recommending a very aggressive line
starting with the move c3 the reason is
after D captures and B captures it's
okay that white pawn structures are
shattered on the Queen side but in
return white get a tremendous attack now
so far I reach this position three times
in my game and these are the moves has
been try by an opponent so in the first
game my opponent try to move Bishop to
e7 now if you're putting place passive
moves such as Bishop to e7 then you
definitely need to punish him and the
way to punish him is playing the move e5
the best response is Knight to g4 and
now you hit this night one more time
with them
h3 and after Knight to f6 you capture
this knife and after G captures we
already shattered black's pawn structure
on the Kings side and not only that on
top of everything we have this thread
that is Queen to d5 and it's a kind of
hard to meet because black doesn't want
to play the move rook to f8 and if he
castle on the King side consequences are
very danger I continue with the move
Bishop to d3 he responded very naturally
with the move d6 but this move is not
good enough I responded with McQueen to
e4 so hitting that 7 the only way to
defend this is to move Fi but after
ampersand the threat remain as it is
my opponent responded with the move rook
to f7 but my next move that is Bishop to
c4 and black lost 10 exchanged so the
game continues with the move Bishop f6
Bishop captures King captures Queen to
at 7 Bishop to g7 and castle on the
Kings side with a completely naked King
finally I want to consider is the move
defy which has a counter attacking the
white bishop but here I am recommending
a endgame line which happens after pawn
captures pawn captures
Queen captures King captures and the
move Bishop to g5 which is quite good
for white so there is a threat of B file
in the game my opponent defended with
the move Knight to d7
I played the move Knight to
three he hit my bishop with the MU at
six I capture his knight he recaptured
and now I played castle on the Queen
side there's a check so my opponent
played King to e7
now I played some forcing move with the
movie Phi he played Knight to d7
I played Knight to d5 so hitting two
spot so my opponent has to forcefully
play the move King to d8 and now when
you have such a leaning development
there should be some tactics and I found
it after some time so right here I
sacrifice my e-pawn with the move e six
he captured it and now I played Knight
to f4 hitting the pawn he defended with
the move rook to e8 and now Knight to d5
and you are about to see what will
happen when one side kept leading down
up there my opponent played initial move
that is e Phi but after Knight to e6
check King to e7 and light to c7 black
has lost and in exchange I hope you
enjoy and learn the beautiful world of
Rosso gambit declined I have put the
detailed analysis of this lines and some
of the lines which I haven't covered in
the video in the PGN which is available
in the description so kindly go to it
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on my video and I'll meet you in the
next lecture of we're also gambit
accepted by